ايران ما كفاها تعدم وتعتقل وتعدى
بالمحتاجين لا كمان اليوم صارت تصدر
قرارات بتتبراء من خلالها من بعض اللاعبات
الايرانيات فبعد بعد ما شاركت في دوره
دوليه من دون حجاب رئيس اتحاد الشطرنج
الايراني اعلن انه اللاعبه ساره خادم لم
تكن تمثل بلاده وعلق على ظهور اللاعب وقال
بانه صار خادم شاركت بحريه وعلى نفقتها
الخاصه وفقه زعمه طبعا اكيد الاعلان يا
جماعه جاب بعد ما شاركت لاعبه ترانس
الايرانيه في دوله دوليه من دون ارتداء
الحجاب لتكون الاحدث من بين رياضيات
ايرانيات
ظهرنا في منافسات من دون ارتداء الحجاب
منذ بدا الاحتجاجات المناهضه للحكومه
صحيفه خبر وزرشي واعتماد قالوا انه لاعبنا
فساد في بطولتي الشطرنج اتبعتين للاتحاد
الدولي للشطرنج في كازاخستان من دون
ارتداء حجاب ونشروا كمان صور تظهر اللاعبه
من دون الحجاب في هذه الدوره بالوقت اللي
ما نشرت ساره خادم اي تعليق لاعلى الدوره
او على التقارير